Go to sleep in a chocolate bar or a can of sardines
and an infectious disease stress ball
that you can squish.
It's episode 16
of LÜT.
Are you tired of wimpy straws that make
you look like a loser?
Well, grab ThinkGeek's food grade Titanium straw.
It tears into fruit like metal justice.
Keep being awesome with this mirror decal
that makes you look like the star
of a press conference. Or
these decals you can use to let guests
accessorise themselves by standing
just the right way. Keep a stash of
temporary stache-tous handy
to quickly turn your finger into what
you must...stache.
Then lay back on your hamburger bean
bag. It's not cheap,
but come, a diamond-shaped bean bag?
That's almost as classy
as liquor scented soaps.
Your butt is not clean
until it smells like a whiskey sour.
Also on Etsy are these adorable punk kitties
Hank
e-mailed me about. His friend makes them
and he says each one is handmade and
completely unique,
there will never be another one like it.
Speaking of e-mail,
these Air Swimmers also wound up in my
inbox. Remote-controlled
floating balloons you can scare cats with.
But if you're sick of e-mailing
you're gonna love today's free thing.
Snail Mail
My Email is a project started by Ivan Cash.
All you have to do
is send an email with the recipient's address
to snailmailmyemail@gmail.com by
August 15th. A team of volunteers will then
hand-write your message
and mail it to who you say. Write your
own awesome messages in this notebook,
where instead of blank paper you're given
blank New York City walls and trucks
that your notes and doodles can deface.
As a final escape from modern technology,
transform your iPhone 4
into an old leather book and then enter the future
with this amazing Levitron I found on Vat19.
It can hold objects up to
12 ounces
and automatically adjusts when they move
or change weight.
Here's a wine stopper that makes the
bottle look like a message in a bottle,
but if you prefer your potent portables quantifiable,
use this glass, which has markings
designating exact servings
of spirits, beer and wine.
Beastie Boys action figures,
a spoon action figure, a miniature camera
that's a USB flash drive
and a flash drive that's... fresh.
Beans can be fun when they come in a can.
Water this and when the seed grows
it'll sprout with a message written on
it.
If you live in or near London,
I'm gonna be there this weekend
at Summer in the City. It's an awesome
get together for cool people
and cool YouTubers
and if you can make it, I'll be there -
Vsauce unite. Speaking of Vsauce,
are you subscribed to be Vsauce2
yet? If not, you're missing out on
knowledge. There's a brand new episode of
Mind Blow over there right now.
So, what are you waiting for?
Click here to got watch it.
And as always,
thanks for watching.